مساعدات امريكيه بمليرين ونصف مليار دولار
لاوكرانيا ومدير سي اي اي يطلع زيلين سكي
على خطه روسيا في الحرب
وزراء دفاع الناتو يجتمعون في قاعده
برلين اذا رفضت ارسال الدبابات
تحصل على موافقه لاستخدام لقاح ضد
اوميكرام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النشره المفصله
من العربيه زارا مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه ويليامبيرز العاصمه العثمانيه
كييف سرا والتقى خلالها
الرئيسكي خلال الزياره على خطه روسيا
العسكريه خلال الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله
مصادر واشنطن بوست في هذا السياق اوضحت ان
مدير المخابرات الامريكيه اكد استمرار دعم
واشنطن
في وقت
الاستمرار هذا الدعم بعد سيطره الجمهوريين
على مجلس النواب
زيارته بيان تتضامن مع اعلنت عنه وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه بشان حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه تصل الى
مليارين ونصف مليار دولار
بسحب المعدات العسكريه من مخزونات وزاره
الدفاع وارسالها لاوكرانيا وستثمر الحزمه
الجديده ده خائر لصواريخ ارض جو متقدمه من
طراز ناس بالاضافه الى ثمانيه انظمه دفاع
جوي من غاز افنجر كما تشمل تسعه و
5090 صاروخته المضاد دبابات ومئات الاعلاف
من الدخائر
295000 طلقه من ذخيره خمسه وعشرين ملم
من ذوي المدافع هذا الى نيران التحذير
والوعيد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي حظر الغرب من مساعد تسليح اوكرانيا
باسلحه ثقيله وانظمه هجوميه
متواعدا بان خساره قوه النوويه مثل روسيا
في حرب تقليديه ستؤدي الى اندلاع حرب
النوويه تحذير عززه الكرملين واكد
بالاضافه ان تحضيرات من الحرب النوويه
تتوافق تماما مع العقيده النوويه الروسيه
يتزمن ذلك مع تحولات جذريه
رساله لقياف لمساعدتها في ضرب شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وفقا
يورك تايمز الصحيفه اضافت انه بعد اشهر من
المناقشات مع ودينا الاوكرانيين بدات
ادارته بيد اخيره لاعتراف بانك قد تحتاج
الى القوه لضرب هذا الملاذ الروسيه حتى لو
كانت هذه الخطوه ستزيد من خطر التصعيد
القرم الواقعه بين البحر الاسود وبحر اذوب
موطن لعشرات الالاف من الجنود الروس روسيا
تعتمد الى حد كبير على قواعدها العسكريه
في شبه جزيره القرم في شن هجمات مكانتها
من الاستيلاء على الاراضي جنوبيه اوكرانيا
العام الماضي
الولايات المتحده اصرت ولسنوات على ان
القرم لا تزال جزءا من اوكرانيا
اعطونا اسلحتكم سنستعيد ارضنا
جزيره القرم تعود لواجهه الاحداث من جديد
مسار اخر تدخله الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
مع سعي كل طرف للسيطره على كامل اراضي شبه
جزيره القرم
وز
الالمانيه
عن تعيينه وزير الدفاع الجديد
خلف للوزيره كريستيانو
الغربيين وكانت المانيا
الى اوكرانيا
قد يؤدي الى تصعيد الحرب مع روسيا
وقبل هذا الاجتماع حدثت بولندا على لسان
نائب وزير الخارجيه باتخاد خطوه استثنائيه
حين عرضت المانيا ارسال دبابات اليوبار
الى اوكرانيا الخارجيه البولنديه لم تكشف
عن فحو الخطوه لكن يبدو ان تصيد في الموقف
البولندي يخفي خلافا جوهريا بين وارسو و
برلين حول التعاطي مع حرب اوكرانيا
قال مسؤول عسكري كبير
للحلف حتى لو هزم قواتها في اوكرانيا وقال
الاميرات رئيس اللجنه العسكريه مهما كانت
نتيجه الحرب ان تكون روسي طموحات ممثله
وبالتالي اين التهديد
واضاف انه في الوقت الذي تستنفذ فيه الحرب
وقوات روسيا واعتادها ودخيرتها فان حلف
تتوقع ان تحاول موسكو اعاده ميناء قدراتها
العسكريا
مشاهدينا معنا
هو الاحدث من سلسله الاجتماعيات
على خلفيه هذه الحرب الروسيه اوكرانيه كيف
بدات الاجواء التي تستبق انعقاد هذا
الاجتماع اليوم
ستكون هذه الكلمه منقوله لذلك يعني سنعرف
ما الذي سيقول استعدادا لهذا الاجتماع
وهذا يعني ربما يناقد الكلام الذي تنقلته
وسائل الاعلام الالمانيه وغيرها في
الايام المستشار الالماني او لاف شونس قال
بانه هذا الشرط اساسي لالمانيا لكي ترسل
دبابات لافرز الى
ولكن هو قال انه ليس على علم بان هناك
رابط بهذا الشكل وقال ايضا بانه قرار
ارسال المانيا دبابات لفظ الى اوكرانيا
سيتم اتحاده في الايام المقبله ولكن قرار
السماح الدول الاخرى التي تمتلك هذه
الدبابات بان ترسلها لاوكرانيا سيتم
اتخاذه في الساعات المقبله لذلك استماره
مشتاين على الارجح سيخرج بقرار في نهايه
هذا اليوم حول امكانيه السماح على الارجح
سيسمح لي الدول التي تملك الدبابات مثل
لندن بان ترسلها الى اوكرانيا لانه سمعنا
كلام ايضا وتحذير في الواقع من بولندا
بانه حتى ولو لم تحصل على موافقه المانيا
فهي ستقوم بما وصحه رئيس وزراءها يوم امس
لانه همم لذلك
على الارباح ستوافق المانيا في هذا
الاجتماع على ان ترسل الدول التي لديها
هذه الدبابات لاوكرانيا ربما تتروى هي
شخصيا بان
تتخذ الى اوكرانيا ولكن بالفعل يعني هذا
القرار من المتوقع ان يصدر
ايضا
هناك تخوفات من استفزات روسيا بعد ارسال
هذه الدبابه صحيح باختصار رغده
بسبب الرئيسي الذي منع المانيا حتى الان
من ان تتخذ القرار ولكن الضغوط ليست فقط
من داخل الحزب الحاكم من حزب الخضر
والبراليين داخل الحكومه يضغطون جدا على
الاشتراك همم
شكرا
في متابعه معك اكيد هذا اليوم حول هذا
الاجتماع
نفس السفير الروسي ده واشنطن انتولي
انتونوفا مزاعم تهديد روسيا باستخدام
اسلحه نوويه واصفا اياها بالجوفاء وغير
المسؤوله في هذا السياق حذر السفير الروسي
لدى واشنطن من ان استمرار مرهنه الولايات
المتحده على الالحاق هذه الاستراتيجيه
بالقوات الروسيه في ساحه المعركه يقود
العلماء الى سيناريو كارثي واتهم انت نوفل
امريكيين وحلفاؤهم بشن حرب هجينه شامله
الدروس مشيرا الى ما وصفه باستغلال واشنطن
لشركائها في نيته واجبارهم على تمويل
ازدهار المجمع الصناعي العسكري الامريكي
حسب قوله
بحث وزير الدفاع الروسي خلال اتصال هاتفا
مع نظيره بيلاروسيفتور بحث اجراءات راديو
الاستراتيجي واستعدادات التجمع الاقليمي
لقواتين واشارت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في
بيئاته لان الوزيرين بحث اجراءات الردع
الاستراتيجي الجاري تنفيذها والتقدم
المحرز في اعداد التجمع الاقليمي للقوات
هذا وكان نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي الكسندر
مين اعلن ان القوه الروسيه والبيلاروسيه
تدرسين مساله اشراك جميع الامكانات
العسكريه للبلدين
ادخلت روسيا مؤخرا دبابات 90 الى ارض
المعركه في زومباز فما هي مواصفات هذه
الدبابه
[موسيقى]
فصل المشاهدين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد
الى المدعي العام الايراني
بالقوه في السجون الايرانيه
قال وزير خارج ايرلندي ماكل مارتن ان
بلاده ستبدا كل ما باسر هذه الافراج عن
المواطن الفرنسيه ايرلندي الموقوف في
ايران برنامج ايران واكد وزير الخارجيه
الايرلندي انه سيتم فعل كل ما هو ممكن
مشيرا الى ان السلطات بلاده تسعى الى
تامين اطلاق سراحه لاسباب الانسانيه حيث
يعاني من ارهاق جسد الجن ونفسي خطير وفقا
لوكاله فرنسب هذا وكاله ايران اوقفت
برنامج في الان في الثالث من اكتوبر
الماضي حيث كان في رحله عمل مع منظمه
رحلات سياحيه في ايران
قال رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي زين انتهاكات ايران
المتكرره لحاضر الاسلحه الذي تفرضه الامم
المتحده ضد الحوثيين يبهر تجاهلها
الصواريخ للقانون الدولي في الداخل
والخارج وعبر من انجلس عن امتنانه لقيام
البحريه الامريكيه باعتراض شحنه اسلحه
يعتقد انها كانت في طريقها من ايران
لجماعه الحوثي اليمنيه
اعلن البيت الابيض في بيان حول زياره
مستشار الامن القومي الى اسرائيل ايلان
المستشار اكد على مواجهه تحديدا ايران
وشدد الصليبان على الان الولايات المتحده
لن تسمح لطيران ابدا بامتلاك سلاح نوويه
واضاف البيان ان اداره بيض ترفض اي
اجراءات تزويد التوترات بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين الولايات المتحده ستواصل
العامه لدعم محل دولتين والحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي الراهن فيما يتعلق بالاماكن
المقدسه
في محاوله لمواهمه التوقعات بين اداره
بايد وحكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه بمركباتها
المتطرفه غير المقبوله على الامريكيين حول
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في اول
لقاءات رسميه مع اركانها التشديد على
ضروره استمرار التنسيق حول مواجهه ايران
وتجنب المفاجاهات ولا جيم سياسه الاستيطان
ومنع انفجار الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
فيما اوضح نتنياهو ان اولويته تبقى منع
ايران نوويه ورفض العوده لاتفاق معها
من خلال العمل المشترك مع ان يمكننا
مواجهه التحديات واستغلال الفرص ما يقوي
التحالف بيننا والجهد المشترك لوقف برنامج
ايران النووي
نقول تحياتي الرئيس بايدا الملتزم بعمق
بامن اسرائيل وامريكا ملتزمه باسرائيل
التزام فيه مبادئ مشتركه ونعمل بشكل مشترك
لمواجهه التحديات والفرس
سوليبان
الدفاع والخارجيه الاسرائيليين والرئيس
الاسرائيلي كما زعيم المعارضه ايضا وليس
من باب المصادفه ان يطلب الامريكيون من
اسرائيل تجميد خطه استراليا في القدس
الشرقيه المحتله بالتزامن مع زياره
سوليفان وان تشمل الزياره شقا فلسطينيه في
محاوله للربط ما بين حاجه اسرائيل في
الملف الايراني ورغبه واشنطن في عدم تدمير
حل الدولتين على الارض تمام تماما
عليها ان تعمل على وقف كافه الاجراءات
احاديث الجانب من الجانب الاسرائيلي وااا
من اجل فعلا ان همم نتمكن من
ايجاد نوع من الهدوء والاستقرار في الارض
الفلسطينيه المحتله في رام الله التقى
سوليبان الرئيس الفلسطيني ومدير المخابرات
وسمع تحذيرا فلسطينيه من انفجار الوضع
الميداني وانهاء الحل السياسي ومطالبه
بالوفاء بتعهد الاداره الامريكيه باعاده
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
المحتله زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
قال قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه امير فيصل
بن فرحان الاتفاق على اقامه دوله فلسطين
مع اسرائيل وقال الامير فيصل بن فرحان في
مقابله مع التلفزيون
الحقيقيه في المنطقه لن يتحقق الا من خلال
اعطاء الامل للفلسطينيين مشيرا الى ان ذلك
ياتي من خلال فلسطينيين دولتهم وفي سياق
اخر قال وزير خارج السعوديه
للازمه السوريه مشيرا الى انه يتم التعاون
مع الشركاء لاكتشاف طريقه للتعامل مع
الحكومه في دمشق كما اشار الى ان الولايات
المتحده تعد الشركه الامنيه الاكثر نشاطا
في المنطقه
تجاري مهم للمملكه
محكمه الفدراليه امريكيه بتغريب الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ومحامي مبلغا يقارب
المليون دولار ذلك على خلفيه تقديم دعوه
قضائيه سياسيه ضد وزيره الخارجيه السابقه
ان الدعوه القضائيه لم يكن
مضيفا انا الامراء
وان رفع الدعوه تم اساسا بسونيه ولاغراض
سياسيه
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدي من اهميه
الضجه التي اثرت حول وثائق مصنف سريه
مخزنه في شكل غير ملائم بين ممتلك هذه
الخاصه قائلا انها لا تحتوي معلومات مهمه
وردنا على سؤال حول هذا الموضوع طرح عليهم
الصحفيين عند توجهه الى كاليفورنيا اجابه
بيض اعتقد انكم ستكتشفون انه ليس ثم شيء
هناك
اوضحت اداره الطيران الامريكي ان حذفا
موظفين متقاعدين لملفات دون قصد ادى الى
تعطل نظام الكمبيوتر الرئيسي ووقف الرحلات
المغادره في الحادي عشر من يناير الحريق
وبيان في مواجهه الاوليه ان المشكله حدثت
اثناء عمل الموظفين لتصحيح التزامن بين
قاعده البيانات الرئيسيه الحاليه وقاعده
بيانات الاحتياطيه وبالتالي تعطيه لاكثر
من احد عشر الف رحله جويه على مستوى
البلاد هذا هو نفذ اضافه الطيران موجوده
اي دليل حتى اللحظه على هجوم الكترونيه
خبيثه ووافقه تعبيرها
تشهد سواحل ليبيا منذ سنوات
مكافحه الهجره وحضر عمليه
باكثر من مليون
الذين تمكنا من الوصول الى السفينه وهي في
عرض البحر
الاولى على بعد ما يقارب 20 ميلا من شواطئ
زوارا في اقصى الغرب الليبيه داخل السفينه
8 اشخاص من الجنسيه الهنديه قالوا حسب ما
افادتنا به اداره مكافحه الهجره والتوطين
بجهاز دعم الاستقرار انهم جاؤوا مرفا
المسؤولون هنا يقولون انهم اجبروا على
ايقاف السفينه في ارض البحر وعدم دخولها
للمدرسه لانه غير معدل لرسوله سفن بهذا
الحجم وهم الان يعملون على استكمال
الاجراءات وتسليمها الى جهات الاتصال
وحالات الاشتباه من الشبه في شيء
ونطلب من اجراءاته ولما تم استيقافها طلعت
سفينه مالطيه ما دخول غير شرعيه
مستباحه للمياه الدوله الليبيه من جميع
الاماكن تهريب الوقود الى اوروبا ودول
الجوار يستنزف والاقتصاد الليبيه بشكل
مستمر فيما يقدر الانفاق على دعم
المحروقات سنويا من الدوله
ما يعادل مليارين دولار امريكي تقريبا
اما في تونس فقد بحث وزير خارجيه وداخليه
ايطاليا مع السلطه التونسيه مساله الهجره
غير النظاميه وضروره اعتماد مقاربه شامله
لهذه الظاهره التي تقض مضاجع على عائلات
التونسيه
بن عروس استقبلتنا السيده لطيفه حامله
صوره ابنها بين يديها وتخنقها العبارات في
حديثها عنه هي واحده من الاف الامهات التي
اكتوينا بنار الهجره غير النظاميه
حكايتها تعود الى 12 سنه خلت عندما ركب
ابنها الصبر احد قوارب الموت رغم تحصيله
شهاده جامعيه ومنذ ذلك الحين وهي تنتظر
عودته
حاشي بودي ولولا اللي معه
الانتظار صاحبي
المتوسطي احلام جولي التونسيين الباحثين
عن مستقبل احلام
الموت والهجره غير النظاميه جثث الالاف من
اصحابها في واحده من اقصى قصص المعاناه
الانسانيه التي قد لا تكفي المعالجه
الامنيه لايجاد حل لها قصه صبري والاف
المهاجرين غير نظامين تؤرق السلطات
التونسيه ونظيرتها الايطاليه وزراء
الخارجيه والداخليه الايطاليين يحلان
بتونس وعلى طويله النقاش مع المسؤولين
التونسيين هذا الملف شائك اما ما رشح فهو
ضروره اعتماد مقاربه شامله لهذه الظاهره
تتجاوز البعد الامنيه
للهجره اكدنا مجددا انه يجب معالجته هذه
الظاهره من جذورها المشكله ليست امنيه فقط
رغم انها كذلك
يجب فهم الاسباب التي تدخل الاف والالاف
لمغادره بلدانهم نحو الضفه الشماليه من
المتوسط وارغم هذه التاكيدات الرسميه تتهم
منظمات المجتمع المدني المعنيه بملف
الهجره تتهم سلطات التونسيه ونظراتها
الاوروبيه بعدم البحث عن اسبابها العميقه
وتوفير الاطر والاليات المناسبه لمعالجه
الظاهره
من السلطه خاصه الايطاليه انها تدفع في
الاموال ليست
سبعه قوارب للحراسه وانما لهؤلاء الشباب
والشابات
وبلغه الارقام وصل 18000 تونسيه السنه
الماضيه الى سواحل الايطاليه فيما بلغ عدد
الواصلين خلال النصف الاول من يناير
الحاليه اكثر من الف و 1700 شخص وليد عبد
الله العربيه تونس
قالت منظمه الصحه
وذلك بالمقارنه بالايام الثمانيه والعشرين
السابقه وفيما وصلت حالات الوفيات الى
ثلاثه وخمسين الف حاله اضافه المنظمه انه
تم الابلاغ عن نحو ثلاثه عشر مليون حاله
اصابه منخفاض قدره 7% خلال الفتره ذاتها
هذا هو اعرب الرئيس الصيني شوجنبيه عن
قلقه من انتشار فايروس كورونا في المناطق
الريفيه من البلاد وفق ما افادت وسائل
الاعلام المحليه كما شدد رئيس الصين على
ضروره بدل المزيد من الجهود لتحسين
الرعايه الطبيه للفئات المعرضه للاصابه
بالفايرس في المناطق الريفيه ومعالجه
النواقص في الوقايه من الاوبئه في هذه
المناطق هذا وتاتي مخاوف الرئيس الصيني في
الوقت الذي يتوقع فيه انتقاله ملايين
الاشخاص الى قراهم قبل بدء الاحتفالات
بالسنه القمريه الجديده
اعلن الشركه سينوفارم الصينيه انها حصلت
على الموافقه لاجراء تجارب سريري على لقاح
ضد متحول او مايكرون واشارت شركه سينوفا
الى ان وحده التكنولوجيا الحيويه التابعه
لها في مدينه شنغهاي عملت على تطوير منصه
خاصه للبحث والتطوير مضيفه ان القدره
الانتاجيه السنويه ستصل الى مليارين جرعه
من الاخر في السنه
وفي الختام مذكره
مساعدات امريكيه في مليارين ونصف مليار
دولار لاوكرانيا
وزراء دفاع نيته يجتمعون في قاعده
من رفض ارسال دبابات الى كيه
اصبحت العالميه تحذر من ارتفاع وفيات
كورونا مجددا وسنفار ما تحصل على موافقه
لاستخدام لقاح ضد او ميكرون
نهايه هذه النشاط المشاهدين
[موسيقى]